[Music]
good afternoon everybody hope everybody
is doing great today
my name is Arnab and this is al it's a
great privilege and we are pretty
excited that you know we are here today
to talk about artificial intelligence
and our perspective on that and it's
really timely because I don't know if
you guys saw the news today we as
Accenture and Google we announced our
strategic partnership of setting up
Accenture Google business group together
and how we will drive transformation in
the industry together around intelligent
enterprises so I am personally very
excited and and we will speak about that
just a quick background you know I've
been recently relocated to us prior to
this I was in Central Europe running our
applied intelligence business out of
Germany for the last five years and just
been here last month and to power up our
AI agenda in the valley and Al and I
have been working together
al is from our strategy practice leading
retail and consumer goods in North
America and we are really trying to
bring the industry transformation you
know together powered by applied
intelligence so very excited to to be
here speaking to all of you so in terms
of you know talking about artificial
intelligence you know I personally
believe being in practice for last 20
years when you know analytics data and I
was not that cool I really believe that
you know this is really one of the most
disruptive phenomena you know we are
seeing in the world after the great
Industrial Revolution we as Accenture we
believe that you know artificial
intelligence is not one single bullet
you know it's not one single technology
but it's the constellation of multiple
technologies coming together and these
combinatorial effect of all of these
technologies is what you know empowers
and enables you know significant
business outcomes and and that's what we
are going to talk about you know Allen
I'm going to talk about today as to how
we are seeing with our clients you know
across industries how are they making
this shift to become an intelligent
Enterprise and we are going to talk
about some of the
client examples their stories and more
importantly talk about how to really
make it happen
you know where to start how to take that
journey you know what are the areas to
focus on so we will be focusing a lot on
that so that you can take home from here
some of those learnings and experiences
that both of us had so right off the bat
you know you would see me speaking about
applied intelligence and that's very
deliberate it's a strategic choice we
have made talking about you know applied
intelligence and not artificial
intelligence and the reason is we
believe that you know when we talk about
artificial intelligence and what it can
do for our businesses and for our
communities it's all about applying it
you know and that's what we believe is
the true potential and one of the things
that we believe is that it's also about
how humans and machines are going to
work together to create this new form of
intelligence right and apply that
intelligence into our businesses and
communities that is going to make it fun
that is going to make it exciting so we
really took a strategic call as
Accenture to you know bring together our
capabilities around you know data and
analytics artificial intelligence and
automation all together and bring it a
global business group called Applied
intelligence that will power up in our
new possibilities and we help our
clients reimagine their businesses in a
completely new way so as we talk about
that let's let's get on the same page
you know
AI is a big buzzword you know a lot of
definitions around it we wanted to share
our view on that how we look at AI and
you know it's our prime belief is that
it's about creating systems and machines
you know intelligent that can help
augment human beings to do their you
know jobs better it helped elevate the
performance of human beings and when we
do that it kind of you can think of this
picture the diagram it's not an eye
chart think of it as a flywheel and you
know it has got kind of three concentric
layers the black circle that you see at
the center is really the you know the
machine learning aspect of AI which
really enables machines and systems to
become much more intelligent
every interaction learned through every
interaction that it goes through so that
it can improve its performance and today
what is happening with AI and what's
going to happen in the future I would
say this is the kernel this is the core
and a lot of investment is happening
here today a lot of advancement is
happening in the whole machine learning
whether it's deep learning or shallow
learning you know this is going to be an
exciting space and it's getting into
mainstream what comes on top of the
learning loop is really the end-to-end
capabilities around AI and as I
mentioned it's the constellation of
multiple capabilities starting from you
know speech recognition text recognition
those kind of capabilities using natural
language processing natural language
generation to things like machine vision
for example and a lot of predictive
algorithms you can have mash all of that
together
powered by the machine learning
capabilities and then on top of that it
really enables organizations to think of
what's the art of the possible how am I
going to apply all of these great
capabilities to solve the business
problem and that's extremely important
and that's what we call as the
application layer these application
layers could be about an intelligent
agent for enabling better customer
interaction and intelligent customer
interaction or personalized customer
interaction this could be about creating
fraud management systems powered by
machine learning capabilities this could
be around you know how do I create a
next generation of personalized
healthcare you know for my patients
right to get the best outcomes so it's
you know it's like people like us here
in the room think of different
possibilities that reimagines the way we
run our business today and and that's in
a nutshell how we look at you know the
whole sphere of AI so when you look at
and when we looked at applied
intelligence ourselves we said you know
the vision of our applied intelligence
business should be around the whole
sphere of human and machine interaction
and collaboration and today if you look
at the newspapers every day there is a
lot of news positive news about how AI
is going to create new jobs new
possibilities but there is also another
side of the news which say there is
going to take away our jobs I think the
answer lies somewhere in the middle
and we believe that that's that's a big
opportunity there is not so much of a
debate of how to create that middle path
and how to apply AI in the business to
drive those outcomes and what's the
right way to start and we believe that
there was a need for a management guide
for business executives like all of us
here to chart that out and we came up
with this book you know called human
plus machine which is really a
management guide to how to drive the aih
and our CTO Paul Doherty and our
managing director Jim Wilson both of
them penned this book and it became a
best-seller over the last few months I
would strongly recommend you know you to
kind of take a look at this book I mean
when I read this book that comes to me
every time you know having been in
practice for last 20 years is that AI is
not futuristic you know it's been there
for last 40 50 years and what's making
it real now is the availability of
computing power the availability of data
and all the api's are available today
that's making it real today we are
looking at companies who are using deep
learning and machine learning
capabilities to sequence the entire
human genome you know for coming up with
personalized medicine and personalized
treatment at the same time we are
looking at speech recognition
capabilities and algorithms that is
really enabling the next generation of
you know human interaction customer
interaction and almost being
representing the brand of the company
you know where AI is becoming the new UI
for for the whole company and and this
is happening right here right now and
that's what we believe that AI is
happening it's available it's achievable
and it's affordable and that makes the
whole discussion so much more exciting
so some of the seminal research that we
did in over the last six to eight months
we interviewed about thousand plus
business executives across the globe few
key things came out and I want to share
with this group
first and foremost 84 85 percent of the
executives that we interviewed indicated
that they are going to invest in AI in
the next three years so obviously a lot
of optimism around it we did the
research around understanding you know
how major economies and and global
industries are kind of looking at
adopting a
and and our research showed that
applying AI is going to help improve
profitability on an average to about 38
percent when you look at all the major
industries it also showed us that it's
going to have a huge potential economic
output boost to the economic output in
the order of about fourteen trillion US
dollars when we look at the 12 major
economies across the globe what it also
showed us was that the whole labor
productivity is going to increase by 40%
you know when you look at time horizon
between now and 2035 and the premise was
really around AI being able to help
augment the human workforce keeping
people at the center but also a big
focus were are around the whole
interaction between human and machine
where a machine is doing a part of the
work handing it over to a human being
and vice versa a new level of
collaboration will start we are going to
completely reimagine the future of work
and future of our workforce and and and
that's going to be extremely extremely
exciting and interesting you know as as
we are going to witness that so having
talked about all of that optimism you
know and all of that potential that AI
and the capabilities are bringing
together what does that pivot means to
you know being an intelligent Enterprise
right and Alan Alan I am going to now
spend the time to talk about the
examples of our of our different client
industries but I want to kind of hone on
you know some of the core principles or
traits that we are seeing with a lot of
the successes that organizations are
having in their AI journey and these are
around the four broad themes the first
one that I would like to highlight is
about how a AI is enabling companies to
become much more flexible much more
agile and I call it as you know
reimagining the whole business process
which is not static which is not
rule-based which is not just following
the standardization principles that has
happened in the in the 90s and the early
2000 what made in the entire business
process that I call as living as
adaptable which is going through you
know
your cycle and a constant learning loop
is taking all the signals coming in from
the different data sources and then
taking the actions and decisions and
constantly learning and you know that
creates a completely new dynamic around
how we manage our businesses and
processes globally the underlying factor
around creating a living and you know
adaptable process is really the data and
available availability of data and
making real-time decisions and that
means the second big trait for you know
AI lead companies is to become data
natives empowering all of our associates
and and workforce to be savvy with data
to be having access to all the data that
is needed to do their jobs better and
ability to make real-time decisions with
the power of data and insights it has a
huge mindset shift that happens when you
move from a process centric organization
to a data-driven business model it's a
different mind shift and leads a lot of
cultural change a lot of leadership
commitment we need to walk the talk and
then the third big area is around the
network effect and the way I
characterize Network effect is how you
take a success in one part of the
business and really democratize that and
industrialize that across the entire
organization successful companies are
able to do that and and when you do that
you are following the whole constant
learning loop cycle which doesn't
recognize organizational boundaries so
you are breaking the you know the silos
that exist within the organization not
just within your organization but across
your end in you know extended supply
chain both with your customers as well
as with your suppliers and that creates
the completely new set of exponential
growth opportunities and when we do all
of these is very important to really be
responsible in terms of how we deploy
the AI systems into our business or into
our daily lives into our society and so
on and so forth and I'm going to talk
about that you know as we go through the
presentation this is going to be very
important aspect to create trust and
reduce the skepticism and concerns that
are
with AI so I wanted to leave you all
with these four things and now we are
going to delve into the examples where
we will touch upon this and bring it to
life and with that I want to welcome Al
and walk us through some of the examples
thank you thank you enough pleasure to
be here I'm excited to talk about it
we're going to talk about four different
industry examples of how we think about
applying applied intelligence and and
some of the audience probably care about
the how and how we used it and we'll
talk definitely talk about that and and
be open to some Q&A on on the mechanics
of what we do but I would also imagine
for most of my conversations I do
strategy work so most of my questions
are usually starting with a why what's
the business case for Applied
Intelligence what's the return on
investment it's a significant investment
if your organization comes from a
history of having never done it before
so the examples we're going to show and
essentially all of our examples really
hit on these five views cases so if
you're out there charged for your team
with creating a business case around
investing in AI look to these five I
think you'll find it but as a broad
coaching I would tell you applied
intelligence is going to change how our
consumers experience our products and
services they are going to change what
even we sell as products and services
how those products and services what
products and services we should sell
will be influenced by it and then lastly
which you're going to see a lot in the
examples how we operate as a business
because of my eye so let's the first
industry will pick on is consumer
engagement so think about brands and
retailers and how the consumers
experience us let's set up a little bit
of the problem state where is the
industry today and where is it going how
is technology changing it just like we
talked about how dramatic this digital
revolution is if you're selling products
either as a retailer or a brand under
the customer in this industry this is
what you face you face and explode
of channels not just that our new ways
of connecting your customer and and
sharing information with your customer
but every one of these channels don't
care who your partner is
every one of these channels now has
development kits and technology
available to be able in the moment of
that content being delivered take the
order
we as product companies and retailers
haven't yet built the infrastructure to
satisfy that order but what the customer
sees is at the moment that they feel a
moment of desire they can reach out to
somebody they trust and say I want it so
we as retailers have to adapt to this we
have to understand and invest in how to
build that but if you think about a
traditional retailer or brand being able
to handle all of the choices that I have
to make about what content to put in
which channel and how to talk to each
individual consumer that's overwhelming
and not doable with our current historic
infrastructure so we as retailers or
brands grew up and built companies and
business models built around wholesale
business models where I bring product
from manufacturer to the end consumer
but all of a sudden if across all of
those channels I'm gonna have all this
persistence of relationships and I'm
gonna have to remember who my customer
is in all of those moments so I can
respond appropriately
it changes the fundamental platform of
retailing we still need all the old
platform essential elements the modes of
means of production the medes oblique
getting that supply to market stores to
distribute marketing to bring the
customer demand but the essence of our
relationship changes because of all of
these digital channels so we start where
I grew up in an industry where I could
go and talk to a customer to drive
growth I could increase their traffic I
can increase their conversion rate or
their basket size those were all the
levels of the business but today if
we're gonna drive growth in our
businesses we really have to move
revenue spending of that customer and we
have to do it competitively so some of
you will recognize the LTV yield
equation on the lower left side but if
you're a traditional retailer you never
built your motor to do that so how do i
how do I start thinking about all the
revenue dollars
the the share of wallet that I have with
that customer the share of occasions the
share of use and really optimize when
and how I'm servicing and touching that
customer can't do that with just my
stored processes and systems you really
need two things you need the ability to
predict an individual customer what
their desires are and how those desires
change over the use occasion and where
they might be at that moment in time and
most of our customers or clients might
have a Laura but we're not talking about
a Laura as a personality we're talking
about Laura J Smith's that lives on one
two three maple drive and goes to work
here and transits on this hub that is a
profound difference for the way we've
built our companies and how we make
decisions around how to deploy money to
drive demand so it's profound in retail
and that secondly is when I get that
demand and she says I have desire and
she's able to reach out to me because
I've built these digital channels how do
I get that serviced or how do I engage
all my trading partners how do I make
the right decision about what inventory
to bring her and who should bring it to
her I can't do that with just people I
need to super power these people so I'll
give you a little example of where we
did it with one retailer this retailer
provides services products and services
and when we walked into the client they
had hired they had gone on a little bit
of hiring that we're going to learn to
use data and analytics and they hired
some data scientists and those data
scientists we're doing multivariate
testing in this particular example I'm
talking about how to market so they
started with marketing in this example
and those data scientists each
individual one could do about three
multivariate tests and a good well run
executable multivariate test would give
them results in three to six weeks
depending on the complexity of the test
if you think and you can understand that
if you understand all those marketing
channels at we just put up on that board
earlier think about all the permutations
if I'm going to go place an ad on search
or I'm going to play something on
YouTube or I'm going to play someone on
Instagram I'm going to play something on
Facebook and then think about making
decisions across all those things the
permutations of what content and what
decisions and what offer
are huge and we were using data
scientists could really mathematically
tackle that and scale tackle that and
about one of those good tests a couple
of those tests every three to six weeks
so the reality is we said we need to get
this so you don't need to be a data
scientist to do it
how about I use applied intelligence to
look at all those permutations to let a
person who's charged with growing demand
and growing revenue yields in this
market pick the targets that she think
is important for a strategy like how do
I retain my existing customers how do i
optimize the lifetime value of a bout
high valued customer how do i target
cross selling different products how do
I increase Market Basket let business
users ask business questions and let
machines scale the quality of that
question by running tens of thousands of
multivariate tests by banane iterate
across all those permutations once you
understand that and about use marketing
because it's relatively understand all
the permutations we have to make as
decision-makers but once you understand
that and build an organization that
could start to use machine learning and
data in that way you don't just stop at
marketing you start thinking about well
I might think about the my product
completely different I might test and
have unique product by market I might
modify my market I could test that
market product before it ever comes I'm
certainly going to use this for price
promotion and placements probably one of
the most as we get to last mile delivery
everywhere placement becomes a strategic
place to use AI that drives the
profitability of your firm so I used a
simple example but hopefully the idea
comes across in consumer products and
retail it's the plot for X the the
plethora of emerging ways the consumer
can talk to us in the need for us to
talk to them individually that requires
us to use machine learning and applied
intelligence and on none of these
examples do we take away the role of the
person we completely redefine their job
I'm going to turn it back to you to
cover the exhibition thank you thank you
l that's that's so powerful you know as
you talk about how we can reimagine the
whole way to engage with customers and
consume
and we being all in this space you know
this is amazing I mean the way you know
right now for example Netflix or Amazon
you know the way they are engaging with
all of us I mean all the investments
they have done you know over the last
many years is really acting the flywheel
effect we can start seeing right so yeah
thanks for stank's for sharing their
story so I'm going to take a you know
little switch now from the consumer to
the Food and Agriculture you know
industry and this is something close to
me given I am such a big foodie we are
seeing a huge application of AI in the
field of Agriculture when you look at
agriculture today statistics shows that
across the world there are over 795
million people who then don't get access
to quality food as we look at the growth
of the population globally over the next
50 years the amount of food that has to
be produced in the different
agricultural farms is going to be much
higher than what has happened over the
last 10,000 years and how can a I really
enable you know to reimagine
agricultural operations and empower
farmers you know to make decisions every
day decisions with the power of
intelligence that is coming in it's it's
a complete change and shift in their
business model we have been working you
know with this client you know who is a
big agricultural manufacturer have you
know acres millions of hectares of
agricultural land and the challenge they
are faced with is a lot of the decisions
in terms of you know which part of the
you know farm with thousands and
thousands of trees and plants being
grown where to put their attention
typically they do a sample size you know
and people would go in into the fields
and they would do their you know samples
and they'll come back and then the lewin
analysis based on that they will take a
lot of gut feel decisions how is the
weather going to look like tomorrow you
know what kind of soil condition we are
seeing today in the sample set where
should I actually do more nutrient
injection why do I need to water my
plants better and so on and so forth but
it's a hugely manual process you know
and
and this is where we came in and we work
with this client you know over the last
couple of years initially our pilot now
we are providing a precision agriculture
service which is nothing but AI at the
center of it starting with being a data
a native being a data a native helping
the client to actually look at data that
is coming in you know from aerial images
with drones flying on the top of the
agricultural farm lands taking aerial
images of to show the kind of distress
that the crops might be at which is not
possible when you go you know down there
looking at you know IOT devices emitting
soil chemical composition information as
well as weather information and
triangulating all of that into a
cloud-based platform applying machine
learning and a lot of machine vision
capabilities on top of that to really
come up with you know predictive
recommendations that can go up to the
farmer and on their mobile device really
giving them guidance and assistance in
terms of what specific intervention
needs to be made you know that
particular day that particular week
based on all the multiple parameters
that we are seeing coming in from the
soil information the weather information
the color of the leaves you know whether
there is wheat formation happening
somewhere which parts of the plantation
that's not actually growing properly in
and giving very personalized
recommendation and targeted
recommendation for the for the farmer
taking it one step further you know
integrating that intelligence back into
the work management system of the
broader agricultural company to help
deployment of the right resources in the
right way in a smarter way and and as we
do that think about the living you know
adaptive process that I mentioned
earlier you know the the farmer the
agricultural operations manager they
became part of that learning loop and
they received the recommendation they
looked at the recommendation took an
action the feedback was good there they
look back the feedback into the learning
system if the if the if the result was
not that great they also provide that
feedback as a result of that the whole
precision agricultural engine you know
started becoming smarter over grid of
time and then it it scaled from applying
to one
particular farmland to hundreds of those
farm lands you know across different
crop varieties over a period of six
months and that's AI at scale
you know industrialized across their
businesses and really you know
completely changing a mind shift this
company came from a mind shift of in the
past you know they would take more
rule-based experience based decisions
and today it's all happening with data
becoming data native and really living
you know the new adaptive agricultural
process where the farmers and the
agricultural you know machine operators
all of them are part of the new AI
learning system providing feedback on
every interaction every iteration and
what what is it result in it results in
higher yield of the produce better
quality optimization of resources water
resources nutrients human labor and
primarily it's augmenting the human to
actually whether it's the farmer or the
operator agricultural operator to make
better decisions make better profits
serve people like you and me with better
quality of food so that's that's one
story I wanted to share in terms of a
journey this is going on is a big
transformation journey and based on the
success and I had an opportunity of
meeting the the person who is running it
he's like a 28 year old guy this is a
family-run business is the son of the
CEO and chairman and he is running it
and it's creating a completely new
cultural shift within their enterprise
which was kind of an archaic business
and now this is the cool part of their
business which is completely changing
the way they operate and the way they
move forward in the business moving
forward so the next one that I wanted to
talk about from there since that I know
I've talked about food and you know all
of you're hungry I guess or gonna have
your lunch the next one I want to talk
about is really about you know creating
safe and secure society and this is this
is really happening now you know this is
what you're seeing here is from the city
of Singapore and they have an initiative
called safe city you know and we had an
opportunity of partnering with them to
really look at all the unstructured data
that is coming in you know from video
recordings that is coming in from all
the natural text information webs and
information you know
social media information looking at all
the traffic signals and traffic patterns
and how to create a you know command
center an AI driven command center that
will help the government to monitor you
know crowd movements across the city's
understanding and predicting how the
crowd behavior is going to look like on
a particular day of the week on a
particular big event they are a game day
how does it look like and based on that
understanding how can we optimize the
whole setting of the city right from
traffic management to you know taking
care of any kind of emergency you know
prevention how many resources we need to
apportion for taking care of any kind of
risks that might happen so on and so
forth you know that's that kind of a new
capability that has been developed what
it also does is not just looking at
predicting crowd behavior but also
anticipate what kind of you know
incidents can happen that might have a
security threat you know or any kind of
risk and how do you actually predict
those in advance and then prepare for
those kind of events in advance so that
you're not taken by surprise when you
look at you know these example it's not
about you know just about how we are
industrializing and scaling this
capability but it's also about a new
capability that is just not possible
with human beings and how we are helping
human beings and one of the example is
for example is the game day going on and
you know thousands of people like as we
go into the game you know into the
stadium one you know one person went
with a backpack and then after two hours
comes out without the backpack the human
being is just not going to you know make
that out but the Machine realizes that
and gives an alert you know this is a
simple example right and obviously it
has to be done in a way that it's
responsible it takes care of privacy and
so forth
but this is a completely new capability
that if you can scale you know is going
to create a much safe and secure
environment for the entire city and you
can scale it across multiple cities I
mean you know in the country that I am
coming from in India our new government
new minister is a big initiative around
digital cities you know there are a
hundred cities that are going you know
getting digitalized and using this smart
city concept and the advantage of AI
that you can actually scale this pretty
fast once you have proven the success
you can then replicate that models
pretty quickly you know across the other
cities and that's I think is a huge huge
power that impacts all of us
the third example you know that I wanted
to share this is this is something we
are applying to ourselves I think al
mentioned you know alluded to that via
the Accenture we run you know apart from
the work that we do in terms of
developing the strategy for our clients
you know executing that strategy through
technology deployment
you know reimagining the whole digital
transformation and then finally we help
our clients manage the operations you
know and this is a big business for
Accenture and we are as we speak over
the last two to three years we are
transforming ourselves we are
reimagining how we manage the business
processes of our clients and we are
applying a I add the core of it to three
key dimensions one of that is obviously
to take cost out but the bigger purpose
is how do we actually enable our
associates you know we have one hundred
and thousand one hundred thousand
associates working in that part of the
business how we enable those associates
to do much higher value-added work how
we enable managing those processes in a
completely new way that is powered by AI
so that it's more accurate you know it's
it's compliance
ready you know it's helping us to manage
any kind of fraud that might be
happening it enables us to manage better
customer relationships and supplier
relationships and that's really the core
purpose you know as to why we are Rema
Rema joining our own business process
business operations with the power of AI
the example here I took from was on
invoice management roughly around in a
year we we work with about 2,000 clients
in this space 200 clients in this space
with over 70 million invoices that goes
through Accenture you know we are
responsible for you know authenticating
those managing those and validating
those it was done with over six thousand
plus you know full-time equivalent
employees who were doing that it was a
hugely manual process and we brought in
you know
artificial intelligence and machine
learning at the core of it that
completely reimagined this process what
we are doing here and we are working
very closely with Google in in driving
this where we are using basically Google
vision API which is really a powerful
out-of-the-box capability that is
helping us to extract the you know the
natural text that is there in the
invoice picture along with the spatial
information you know of that particular
picture and then bringing that together
concatenating that together to extract
features you know from those
concatenations and we created you know
what we call as basically these are
digitalized tokens you know a word with
a position where it is placed and each
of them we are uniquely identifying as
digitalized tokens and then we are
making multiple vectors you know around
those tokens to help create features
that uniquely define that and then those
features are then used to train the deep
learning models which are then fed back
into the life you know system of all the
invoices that we have to validate that
to check for issues errors if there is
any kind of potential fraud or
compliance issue and flag that to the
humans and then the human associate
doesn't have to do all the grunt work
that was being done earlier but now is
more in an advisory role and is more in
a supervisory role whereas all the you
know grunt work of validating checking
you know an accuracy and all of that is
being checked and then there is a green
light given and if there is a green
light given and the human agent has
approved it it goes on for processing if
there are fraud or compliance related
issues or missing information or some
duplicate information some conflicting
information that's flagged off as well
to the human agent and then the human
agent accordingly takes more supervisory
and advisory kind of you know function
from there and the fact that we are
deploying it on Google technology with
the cloud platform it has really helped
us scale from one client to 200 clients
today you know and the fact that we are
managing 70 million invoices in a year
it gives us a huge amount of data sets
with different form factors of invoices
different kind of you know text
orientations and all of that to train
and make our intelligent engine much
more you know efficient as
days go by and we are right now over 90
95 percent accuracy in terms of the you
know checking the validations of these
invoices so that's a huge impact for us
it helps us give better service to our
clients at the same time you know
creates a much more foolproof business
process system so having talked about
you know the examples that I'll talked
about on consumer you know we talked
about you know from how it helps with
agriculture whether it's about
reimagining our own business process I
want to kind of spend time a little bit
now in terms of how to get it right
you know I mean all of these are great
stories we talked about some of the
examples and I want to touch upon three
key tenets or you know secret sauce that
we are seeing that is very important to
get the intelligent enterprise journey
right the first and foremost that we are
seeing with clients were very successful
in this is really figuring out the
human-machine collaboration you know
this is the first see the collaboration
see this is extremely important because
human beings have certain strengths are
on creativity decision-making judgment
whereas the machines have strengths
really around doing things in a
repeatable manner high accuracy high
speed right how do we bring that
together and design systems awry systems
that really take care of these two
angles very well isn't going to be very
very important it is going to address
the fact whether humans are going to
compete absolutely no humans are going
to work together with machines powered
by these AI systems and and you can
think of it almost as if human ingenuity
is actually getting complemented with
intelligent technology and organizations
need to really figure this out very well
and there is and this is not just a
technology play it is about reimagining
the whole you know persona as to who is
going to use that system you know
whether it's that agricultural farmer
whether it is the customer you know
value manager or a marketing manager
whether it's the supply chain manager
whether it is the you know the event
manager who is going to use the AI
system and how he or she can then work
with the machine to actually create a
much higher performance much higher
outcome and keeping that design in in
thinking in in mind when you did
the AI system is extremely critical so
that's the first C the second big focus
is really around capabilities and
capabilities that are end-to-end and I
wanted to touch upon this because people
sometimes feel that capabilities means
technology you know which we have all
talked about so far all the different
algorithms you know all the machine
learning capabilities yes that is great
but that's just one part of the
capability the second big part of the
capability that is required is you know
the fuel for the whole AI system that's
the data that's the data platform you
know how do you get your data supply
chain in place because that's going to
be you know the concrete asset on top of
which you will be actually building all
of these AI systems it's also about how
do you then embed the AI system into
your business functions into your
business processes and that requires a
different skill different capability
around adoption around change management
you know around making sure that
employees are really believing in it and
there is there is the tangible value for
the employees within the organization
and how do you bring all of these
end-to-end capabilities right from
having a strategy of AI to actually
creating the platform enabling all of
these different capabilities that we
spoke about earlier and then how do you
manage the change and the adoption into
the business that creates real
transformation and then the third one
that I want to speak about is as you
think of these capabilities how do you
go about building those and that's where
the third C which is the connections is
extremely important and we are seeing
that and we did a big research on this
last year around how to increase the
artificial intelligent quotient of
organizations and we saw that the
companies which are taking an outside-in
approach by that I mean taking an
approach of bringing innovation not just
from within but from outside working
with startups working with research you
know Institute's working with the
academia they get a boost start you know
compared to the companies which are
trying to do everything in-house so a
critical decision factor that every our
leading organization in the AI space
will have to think about is what they
build on their own what is it that they
want to buy
from you know service provider and what
is it that they borrow what is it that
they get inspired with you know using
the power of startups or the Academy or
the research partners and I think that
partnership ecosystem is going to be
extremely critical especially as we
scale the AI agenda within the companies
so having spoken about that I want to
leave with this last thought is that as
we think of you know reimagining the
business as we think about creating the
transformation we have to do it in a
very responsible way
ai is a profound technology it has a
huge value potential but how do we make
sure that there is a certain level of
accountability that comes in when we are
deploying AI systems how do we make sure
that organizations are thinking about
every stakeholder not just the customer
nor does the supplier the employees the
government the policy makers how we
think of all of those stakeholders right
and how do we create a right amount of
governance model and operating model to
see as decisions are being taken by AI
systems who takes the accountability
whether it is the algorithm which is
accountable whether it is the person who
made the algorithm is accountable
whether it's the person who is actually
the sponsor you know of this whole
initiative who is accountable for that
and these are questions that needs to be
really thought through you know very
very carefully and as you go through the
transformation think about the people
think about the people that needs to be
rescaled that needs to be rotated into
the new AI journey so that we don't
leave anybody you know as we go into the
journey how do we take the people you
know who probably are not skilled who
really don't understand and appreciate
how do we educate them how do we make
them the advocates of the AI journey and
more importantly how do we make them
successful in their career and in their
journey with AI and last but not the
least security how do we make it all
very secure so that there is no bug that
comes into their algorithm which is
running a manufacturing operations or a
customer operations because there is a
lot of reputation risk you know
associated with that how do we how do we
manage that you know in a very
responsible manner so with that I would
like to you know bring it to a close
here personally being in the practice
for so many years I feel you know this
is an amazing field
few things I want us to remember that AI
is all about you know augmenting human
beings how do we think about creating
living and adaptable business processes
and how do we literally make sure that
we are all becoming data and natives and
and enabling that new culture within the
organization and as we do that
how do we make sure we do it in a way
it's responsible it creates trust
transparency and addresses you know
people's concerns and take them together
in that joint
you